فلسطينية بانصاف حلول اقتصادية.
قالت شوشويفسكي وهو مواطن روسي
به منذ عدة ايام بالقرب من
الساحل اليمني في البحر الاحمر
خمسة اخرين في عملية دهس بالقدس
المحتلة نفذها فلسطيني يبلغ من
سفارتها بالسودان الغراوي وذلك
اثناء توجهه الى مقر السفارة في
الضحايا التي تزيد كل يوم. وها
هي منظمة الصحة العالمية تعلن
لهم نصيب من الضحايا وبعد ان تم
اسر جنودهم ثم اعادتهم لوطنهم
خلفت اربعمائة وتسعة وخمسين
قتيلا واكثر من اربعة الاف جريح.
الهدنة. افلا تعقلون ايها
السودانيون? اولم تكفكم اعداد
بها قوات الدعم السريع منذ
الساعات الاولى للهدنة
طرف خصمه بخرق الهدنات الاولى
كان الوضع مشابها في هذه الهدنة
والسعودية بالدفع نحو هدنة
انسانية. وافق عليها الجيش
السوداني وقوات دعم السريع وبدأ
سريانها بسرعة. وبينما يتهم كل
عليها. وبرلين ترى ان التوقيع هو
افضل لينسحب هذا الاختلاف على
الارقام الحقيقية فانها اكبر من
ذلك بكثير. فيال بؤس حالك ايها
الشعب السوداني. الاحداث
والتطورات. مقتل مستوطن واصابة
عداد الضحايا لا يتوقف والدموع
السودانية لا تجد. المصريون كان
اكدت الخارجية الروسية ان موسكو
ستقدم ردا مناسبا وحاسما بحسب
فمتى ستلفظ ساعة الصفر انفاسها
الاخيرة؟ ومن المنابر الغربية
كاملة الدسم تدخل خزائن العم
سام. ولا نسمع طبول الربيع تقرع.
تلبية احتياجاتها العاجلة. فيا
لحظ ابناء العم سام فهذه صفقة
بان الاشتباك الدائرة بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
ليؤكد الجيش السوداني انه رصد
تعزيزات وارتالا عسكرية لقوات
تحلق في سماء الخرطوم ما يمثل
اخلالا بالهدنة. نعم يا اصدقاء
ايضا. هنا الجيش السوداني يعلن
انه رصد الكثير من الخروقات تقوم
حتى لا تذهب اموال امريكا بعيدا
لدول غير صديقة فكوريا تلعب هنا
السودانية تدخل اجواءها القاتمة
سريعا. بين فارين من بابا
المعارك وفصائل متناحرة وتمديدات
دولية وسكان محتجزين في المنازل
والمانيا حول اعادة احياء
الاتفاقية الشاملة للاستثمار بين
واردة الا انها ليست حتمية. فما
الذي تعلمه انت ولا نعلمه نحن يا
الجاري وفق وكالة يونهاب. وكانهم
يقولون سنأتي لزيارتكم ولكننا لن
بوليتكو. هناك اعلنها نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري
نحمل الهدايا معنا. وهنا نقصد
الاسلحة الكورية التي من امريكا
نقرب المسألة لكم اكثر. كوريا
تشتري السلاح من امريكا ومن تحت
يدركون حاجتهم لتحقيق انتصارات
جادة في ارض المعركة وان مصير
والهدف من هذا الهجوم المضلل هو
ارباك القوات الروسية. فهم
المعدات العسكرية الامريكية.
مهلا اهلا اهلا. في كل يوم نسمع
ان خسائر الجيش الاوكراني خلال
الاربعة والعشرين ساعة الماضية
للضفة الشرقية من نهر الدنيبرو
في مقاطعة خرسون جنوبي البلاد.
على متنه ثلاثة روس ومصريان.
فكيف اختفى هذا اليخت? هل اصبحت
مقيم في الامارات ومالك احد
اليخوت الخاصة انه فقد يختا خاصا
الاوروبي يواصلان محاولاتهما
الهدامة للالتفاف على حل القضية
وزير الخارجية الروسي سيرجي
لافروف ان واشنطن والاتحاد
العمر تسعة وثلاثين عاما وهو من
بيت صاف بالقدس المحتلة. اكد
ممثلة مفوضية الامم المتحدة
للاجئين انه تم تسجيل عبور اربعة
الاف شخص من السودان الى تشاد.
وهذه الارقام التي يعرفونها. اما
الخرطوم لمتابعة اجراءات اجلاء
المصريين من السودان حسب وكالة
اكدت وزارة الخارجية المصرية
مقتل مساعد الملحق الاداري في
ام انها حرب اعلامية الى جانب
المعارك العسكرية؟ وفي خضم الحرب
الاوكرانية ان الجيش الاوكراني
بدأ ما سمتها عملية تطهير للشريط
والاشتباكات بالاسلحة الثقيلة
عادت للخرطوم فجر اول ايام
السودان حتى اكدت التقارير
الاعلامية ان اصوات القذائف
السريع من جانبها وجهت الاتهامات
ذاتها للجيش بالخروقات. وقال
الدعم السريع قادمة من غرب
السودان الى الخرطوم. قوات الدعم
لا يعلمون ما الذي يجري في
الخارج. لتتدخل الولايات المتحدة
لم تمض سوى ساعات قليلة على دخول
الهدنة الجديدة حيز التنفيذ في
الاوروبي حول العلاقة التجارية
مع الصين خصوصا مع خلاف فرنسا
سبوفنيك. في الحرب السودانية
ضحايا لكن من نوع اخر. حيث قالت
يجري? روسيا تفي بوعدها وتجمع
الاعداء على طاولة واحدة. وفي
عقد لقاء بين وزراء دفاع ورؤساء
استخبارات تركيا وروسيا وسوريا
لا تنتهي. الحرب الروسية
الاوكرانية تستأنف مدها وجزرها
لتصبح شراكة عسكرية وسياسية? من
يدري فاصحاب العيون الضيقة لا
التجاري الاول للاتحاد مقصية
بذلك الولايات المتحدة والتي ظلت
الاتحاد الاوروبي باكمله خصوصا
بعد ان اصبحت الصين الشريك
الصين واوروبا. باريس تريد اعادة
تدقيق الاتفاقية قبل التوقيع
وكالة نافوستي. ولا زلنا في
العاصمة الروسية موسكو حيث تم
الناطق الرسمي باسم قوات الدعم
السريع ان طائرات الجيش لا تزال
وايران في اطار محاولة روسيا
لملمة اوراق الجيران الاعداء.
بطعمها الى فم اوروبا والناتي
انقسامات اوروبية. فما الذي
قوات كييف باخموت لتعلن المتحدثة
باسم قيادة عمليات الجنوب
لعقود الشريك المقرب للاوروبيين.
فهل تتطور الشراكة التجارية
يكفون عن جذب العالم نحوهم. هدنة
سودانية بضمانة سعودية. الحرب
لاستغلال الهدنة لانقاذ ما وصفه
بموقفها الميداني المتدهور.
بحقه الكامل في التعامل مع
الخروقات قوات الدعم السريع
الانسانية. وقال الجيش السوداني
انه رغم التزامه بالهدنة فسيحتفظ
الطاولة تبيعه لاوكرانيا. والهدف
الحصول على المساعدات الغربية
دور السمسار لا اكثر. ومع نضوب
الاسلحة الغربية في واقتراب
الهزيمة جاءت جرعة امل اوروبية
جديدة. حيث قالت رئيسة المفوضية
الى الحرب الدبلوماسية. وبعد طرد
السويد لخمسة دبلوماسيين روس
وضخمة تروي ضم القوات الاوكرانية
وكييف تنشر معلومات مضللة. فما
الاوروبية ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
خصص شريحة اخرى من المساعدة
ومن تجمع حلفاء موسكو الى انقسام
اعدائها حيث تصاعد الانقسام
وذلك وفقا لتصريحات سابقة للرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكون ولكي
والمعدات العسكرية ليست على
اجندة القمة التي ستعقد بين
كوريا الجنوبية لاوكرانيا. لا
اسلحة لكم منا بالمجان. اسمعتم
لاوكرانيا بمبلغ مليار ونصف
المليار يورو لمساعدتها على
الاعلامية؟ هنا الاوكران يعمدون
الى نشر اكبر قدر ممكن من
المعلومات المضللة حول زمان
ومكان الهجوم المضاد المرتقب
عن مئات القتلى والجرحى من
الطرفين فهل هذه الارقام واقعية
يصبح الوضع امنا بدرجة كافية.
هنا وزارة الدفاع الروسية قالت
هذا الصراع يعتمد على نتائج
هجومهم المضاد وفق صحيفة
ميدفيديف صريحة بقوله ان
احتمالات اندلاع حرب علنية جديدة
مشيرة الى ان عمليات الجيش في
خرسون تتطلب صمتا اعلاميا حتى
الرئيسين يونسو كيول ونظيره
الامريكي جو بايدن الاسبوع
وصلت الى ستمائة وخمسة واربعين
جنديا اضافة الى تدمير عدد من
هذا كوريا الجنوبية اخذت حاتم
دفيدف على محمل الجد. حيث افاد
مسؤول كوري جنوبي بان مسألة
امداد سيئون لكييف بالاسلحة
والقوات بين كر وفر. حيث تواصل
قوات فاجنر انهاء ما تبقى من
توقعان اتفاقات تاريخية واصوات
الضحكات ترتفع والولايات المتحدة
رعاياها. فالى اين المصير?
وايران والسعودية اعداء الامس
وروسيا تتوعد السويد برد عسكري.
واوروبا تقدم حزمة مساعدات جديدة
تسد اذنيها. والسواحل اليمنية
يختا اماراتيا فاين اختفى؟ حروب
سواحل اليمن مثلث
السودان هدنة جديدة والخروقات لا
تتوقف. بينما تستمر الدول بسحب
هي الغاية? وبين خرسون وبخموت من
يتقدم ومن يتراجع. وبكين ترمي